dooms executive producer Marty Stratton
spoke to gain [ __ ] at quakecon recently
and gave us a bunch of new details about
the upcoming shooter Stratton revealed
that adds software is very concerned
with ensuring that the game will run at
1080p and 60 frames per second he
explains we've always been at the
forefront of saying we want our games to
run as fast as possible at the highest
resolution possible so for us that goal
is 1080p and 60fps along with that goal
the mantra of our technology team is
that we want to be the best looking game
out there at 60fps and 1080p he adds
that this isn't simply a technical goal
for the studio but a desire to deliver a
high quality experience that puts
gameplay first a feat they only see as
possible by employing a fast fluid 60
frames per second Stratton also
explained that even though it's software
is making competitive multiplayer a big
part of the game they aren't worrying
about its eSports potential even though
it's quake series was one of the first
major sports titles he said they're just
quote really working on how we can
entertain millions of people on their
cultures every day through launches in
2016 for ps4 xbox one and pc for all the
latest on doom and everything else that
came out of quake can be sure to stay
tuned against what